i have seen the meme of eric andre
saying tinashe where are you at but
yeah i'm right here
hey
hey what's up everyone i'm tinashe and
today i'm going to be sampling chips
from all over the world
[Music]
so first up we got
classic blaze
i mean how can you beat them this is
your standard potato chip
i don't know how you can really get
better than lace we're gonna see today
i love chips they're pretty much the
only snack that i really genuinely enjoy
like other snacks like i'll eat them if
they're there and i'm like hungry but
i'm really looking for the chips i also
like to eat a chip in one bite you're
gonna like make crumbs if you just eat
it in half you just gotta like
salty crunchy like what more could you
want in a snack on a scale of one to ten
i'm giving a classic late potato chip a
ten but i'm interested to see if any of
the other chips come close today okay
let's see
next up we've got
some takoyaki pringles from japan the
packaging is really intriguing it looks
really festive so they already drew me
in
the packaging is hard to open you know
child proof okay i actually just found
out that takoyaki is octopus
which is you know not typically my go-to
chip flavor
i guess now that i look at it there's
little octop octopi they smell kind of
like cinnamon okay let's give it a go
what i got to lose let's do it
okay
it's kind of sweet it's giving like a
hint of a barbecue flavor i'll give
these a a four out of ten i'm not a fan
when i go overseas to do a show i
typically try to try like the local
cuisine the local street foods i haven't
had a takoyaki yet so i might have to
put that on my list
maybe but i do like to you know try to
be a part of the culture as much as i
can like try to experience the city i
love japan japan is one of my absolute
favorite countries to visit i've shot
videos there i did one for save room for
us which is really amazing every time i
have a show there they go crazy so i got
a lot of love for japan but maybe not
the takoyaki pringles
next up
we have ketchup cheetos from canada
um
this looks sus you guys i don't know
this looks super sus why are we
flavoring things like ketchup i don't
really like ketchup to begin with i
don't really like cheetos to begin with
mix the two together this is like my
worst nightmare well let's give it a go
dangerously canadian it says on the back
they smell like catch up
ew
okay
oh my god
that gives me the hippie chibis
this is so gross
oh my god one out of ten maybe if i was
canadian i don't understand it shout out
to canada
next up we have
river snail blaze from china
so okay so my first question is is this
a potato chip that's flavored like a
river snail or is this a river snail
that they made into a chip
i see some ingredients spicy noodle
flavor
potato vegetable oil snail powder okay
good so i'm not eating a full snail
just powdered version
again this is child proof
smell test it smells kind of spicy
i'm breaking my own rule i'm only gonna
eat half
confusing flavor i'm gonna walk you
through it at first it tastes spicy
then it starts tasting kind of like a
seafoody
it's a little tangy
if you will i like these better than the
than the ketchup chips i'm not even
gonna lie so i'll give these a
three out of ten
okay hang on i need to take a break from
the chips for a second my palette is
overwhelmed i want to tell you guys
about my new album 333 is out now i'm
really excited about it i've been
working on it for 18 months now i have
so many dope collaborations on the
project it feels like me but it feels
fresh it feels new so definitely go
check it out go listen to 333
[Music]
we got some hot chili squid leis from
thailand oh see this is like the ideal
like chip like width like see how it's
like real
real crispy you can like almost see
through it like that's my favorite
okay
the flavor is mild so it's not that hot
considering it's like a hot chili flavor
it's not that hot i thought it was gonna
be spicy yeah these are these are pretty
good i'm gonna give those a
4 out of 10. i did hot ones a few years
ago and my spice tolerance i think was
like pretty good i think i was pretty
impressive these were not very spicy so
the fact that they're called hot chili
squid i think is like a little bit
misleading just a little i wanted to
start sweating like once my upper lip
starts sweating then it's like oh those
are hot those are really hot i have seen
the meme of eric andre saying tinashe
where are you at to not say where you at
but yeah i'm right here
hey
last stop
we have soy chili garlic cheetos from
korea let's give them a go
oh my god i can't open them
i'm gonna have to old spool it
oh my god i can't open them
looking a little different than your
average cheeto
they're a lot lighter in color
[Music]
okay
they're a little sweet the flavors are
just so complex i like these give these
a seven out of ten
all right there you have it i tried a
lot of chips today my taste buds went on
a little bit of an adventure shout out
to every country because i love you guys
and i appreciate you even if i am not a
huge fan of your chips so thank you guys
so much for watching make sure that you
check out my new album 333 available now
streaming on all platforms and i'll see
you guys next time bye
[Music]
tinashe where you at